hey check out these titles don't they
look fancy fancy titles make everything
I say seem really interesting the
unimportant therefore I'll say some
really dumb and unimportant things
bazinga
scram tiny little doggies boobie button
there you go
so it might seem like we've wasted a
bunch of time and after putting that
opening together but we didn't that's
the beauty of a perfection videoblocks
calm actually approached us NASA we
could make a video talking about them
and how to use them so it figured yeah
why not yeah that's a good reason to
talk about sucks at it unlike say ok
unlike maybe Sam not everyone is the
best motion graphics artist in the world
wow that's I'm really hyping you up yeah
Jesus
so anyways not everybody it's a killer
motion graphics artists and not
everybody has the time to make killer
motion graphics and that's where
templates can really come in and help
you spice things up just that's spiced
on there since this videos getting a
little dry I'm gonna throw some graphics
up in here yeah it's are a great way to
spice things up and if you're working on
a deal for a client actually a great way
to impress them because it adds a lot of
easy production design yeah business mmm
easy to use a for easy low grata G video
opener or like if you have honestly if
you have kind of like drive over its
kind of boring like this you're some dry
and boring voice over it spruce it up
with some graphics it makes it a lot
more palatable yeah a lot more colorful
I love gaggy so some of you out there
might not like the idea of using stock
stuff that someone else has already made
you'll want things to be unique in
custom the thing is templates can also
just save you time when you are going to
get your hands into an After Effects
file rather than starting from a blank
project file which is way harder start
from something that's already there get
something that's kind of close and alter
it manipulate it you want something
that's unique you're not unique yeah
template oh my god there's a bee and all
seriousness when it's it's perfect for
doing stuffing in the background things
that need to look cool but aren't gonna
have even the most attention put on it
also they're great for news broadcasts
and fake news broadcasts they're
especially good for fake ones you can
use them for funny purposes like just
tear it apart alter it see if we can
make it fit put your own little pizzazz
make it your own or if you're lucky you
can find exactly what you want and well
there you go what you want come on
you're too busy directing just grab grab
the template it goes like I want a
template I'm like coming right up
handy families like great I love
templates they're so fast I'm like
you're right they are so if you're
watching this video chances are you on a
mess around some After Effects templates
yourself you head over to video box they
have a seven day trial that's a bad way
to get your library started don't forget
though the roles were into a real
subscription after the seven days so set
an alarm make sure you're prepared for
that real subscription when it hits so
now that the video is over for anything
of a solid outro for you guys I think
this is it see ya
am I still in France so I wasn't you
don't know you said Randall on behind
the scenes but now he's our life
equation seriously render fired also a
position is just open that we'd like you
to fill and Carmichael is the new behind
the scenes guy and he's all about those
little idiosyncrasies don't smile for
this last thing I think that's what's
missing
anyways I hope you guys found this at
least somewhat useful I really hope you
get did because you know I never done
like sports overlays templates you
should do